Rosalie for you I have to go back not
ahead because we have a lot of 1899 fans
who read and watch our content who are
very very sad about what happened yeah
we've heard that the plan was to have
three seasons it's kind of like dark I'm
not sure how much information you knew
about what was lying ahead for your
character but is there any particular
layer you were really itching to explore
oh my goodness absolutely I mean it was
just talking about you know having
artistic vision and that is that is
again a a fierce couple who make
extraordinary uh art I think
um yeah there was so much for Virginia
out there I mean I was definitely one of
the characters who was
um about ready to come into our own in
in season two and you maybe would find
out why she's so dark so evil and um
just driven the way she is I mean I know
those things
um but I was really excited about
exploring them but this is this is we
are I think 1899 is a product of what
we're experiencing algorithms and things
not given their life that the proper
life they deserved bone yancha are
people who create series which take time
they're not binge-worthy and you have to
sit with the with the pieces of Art and
think about them and wait for them to
develop but we live in an instant
Society so we're a product of that
unfortunately